[Music]
the veneers of denial were starting to
fall away and I was starting to get a
picture of the truth of how I was living
what I thought was cool ultimately
turned out to be something very dark but
ultimately you know I reached that point
that you here with other people in
recovery that that point of no return
where you wake up and you finally have a
willingness to do whatever it takes and
that's when I ended up in a rehab in
Oregon the challenge of crashing and
having to pick yourself back up is
really what reveals character like
that's the test if my journeys been
about anything it's about kind of
trusting those whispers and being
willing to have faith and invest in
those little signals that are just so
faint and yet potentially life-altering
and meaningful you know and everything
good in my life has come as an outgrowth
of putting service first and recovery
first and just allowing whatever else is
going to come come yes that's right you
heard it correctly that is indeed me
rich role and this is the rich role
podcast
[Music]
the rich roll podcast so I'm gonna do
something a little bit different today
either I'm getting mushy with age or
perhaps on evolving a bit I choose to
believe it's the latter but either way
I've been feeling a great deal of
gratitude as of late all of you guys the
audience has a great deal to do with
this emotion and I just wanted to
publicly acknowledge it and and take a
moment to reflect on the journey that
got me to this place because I think
it's important to stop for a beat to
honor yourself and more than that those
that helped get you where you are for
those relatively new to the show who who
might not know that much about my
personal story about 13 years ago I was
somebody who I would characterize as
relatively disconnected from my higher
self and although I had strung together
some years sober after many years lost
in the throes of alcohol
I found myself stuck in a career that
didn't serve me I was unhealthy I was
overweight and essentially totally blind
to the best path forward ultimately I
found this way out it was a journey that
began with diet and nutrition and
fitness that took me places I never
thought possible conquering
ultra-endurance challenges previously
unimaginable and ultimately reinventing
my life
wholesale along the way and then about
eight years ago I published a memoir
chronicling that journey called finding
ultra and that book changed a lot for me
and for other people and I've continued
to grow and evolve and misstep and fail
and learn since that moment and look I'm
not unaware that today I have this
amazing privilege of living this life
that is basically well beyond my wildest
imagination but I will also freely admit
that I often lose sight of this fact
daily at times focused on finishing up
the next project or lost in thought
about the work that remains the stones
that are unturned the past mistakes that
are unrecognizable
and I need to be reminded all the time
that it's important to take off those
blinders to stop for a moment to reflect
back to honor the path you blazed and
and express gratitude for those in your
life that support you because nobody
nobody achieves dreams alone when
outside Magazine reached out to me a
couple months ago saying that they
wanted to put me on the cover of their
January issue I honestly thought that
I'd misheard them unlike so many of my
heroes who have graced the cover of this
iconic publication over the years I
didn't see myself anywhere near that
category I'm not an Olympic champion I'm
not a world-class adventurer I've never
even won a big race my books never made
the New York Times bestseller list and
my podcast which I love and which is
phenomenal is hardly the largest but
this has been a really proud moment for
me it's an honor that I receive with
gratitude and a whopping dose of
humility and alongside that honor was
this opportunity to be a guest on the
outside podcast which kind of served as
part of the interview that was conducted
by Peter vikner on who wrote the article
in the publication and a conversation
that was in turn beautifully produced
and written and edited by Michael
Roberts with music by Robbie Carver over
the years I've guessed it on a ton of
great shows I've been on Joe Rogan twice
impact Theory Good Life project school
of greatness Gary Vee Adam Carolla James
all teacher and many many other great
shows which I will link in the show
notes but I've never repurposed any of
those experiences on this feed but this
conversation really stands out to me I
think it captures the best of how I
explain and think about this wild
journey that I've been on and perhaps
even more importantly what can be
gleaned from it for the benefit of
others so I'm doing what I've never done
before and I'm reassuring that
conversation with all of you guys today
but first let's take care of some
business
we're brought to you today by fully the
coolest best designed
environmentally-friendly and ethically
manufactured office furniture on the
entire
at earth I've been talking about fully
for a few years at this point how their
Jarvis standing desk and capisco chairs
have totally transformed my workspace my
personal studio but guess what fully now
has goods for the whole team designed
for health flow imbalance full ease
workplace furniture now offers solutions
for everybody you work with all your
colleagues instead of feeling chained to
your desk in a cubicle farm or out of
place in an open space fully is making
work at the office feel more like
working from home their collection of
active chairs lounge seating conference
tables room dividers and other workplace
accessories are all designed to recharge
and replenish your energy throughout the
day that's because each of Foley's
product supports movement keeping your
blood flowing and your mind engaged from
product selection to space planning and
delivery the fine folks have fully are
here to help your team bring their full
active selves to work and right now you
can get $50 off the Jarvis standing desk
when you visit fully calm / rich roll
that's F ull why.com / rich roll for 50
bucks off the Jarvis standing desk fully
the new way to work we're also brought
to you today by Harry's listen you guys
we know at this point that shaving is a
pretty simple straightforward activity I
don't know why we over complicate it all
you need for a great shave is a sharp
blade and quality design and that's what
Harry's is all about quality
craftsmanship at a fair price
Harry's combined a simple organ AMA cos
I know five slick blades manufactured in
the world-class Factory in Germany while
cutting out the middleman and shipping
directly to you so you get premium blade
refills as low as two dollars each
two dollars each no markups no gimmicks
and I can tell you as a longtime
Harry's customer everything that they
make is very beautifully crafted they
just nail the basics and they dispense
with all the additional nonsense you
don't need fancy packaging or crazy
color schemes and stripes and motors and
all this kind of stuff that shaving
accoutrements tend to have these days I
just want a great shave at
fair price I like the transparency of
the company
I love how sharp the Harries razor is I
like how fresh the blades are and that
they're delivered right to my doorstep
so I don't have to hassle at the
pharmacy I never have to drag a dull
blade across my face anymore in between
shades it's all a godsend and the handle
has such a nice feel to its polished
I love the heft and the control that it
gives me shaving this is a high class
razor people that I know you're gonna
dig so go to harrys.com for slash roll
and all you new customers will get five
dollars off a trial set that includes a
five blade razor a weighted handle
foaming shave gel with aloe and a travel
cover that's a pretty sweet deal so just
go to harrys.com forward slash roll to
start shaving better today we're also
brought to you today by seed did you
know that your body is made up of half
human cells and half microbial cells it
may sound a little bit creepy but those
little microbes are far more friend than
foe in fact ensuring the health of our
gut flora is absolutely crucial to
maintaining health they digest our food
they regulate inflammation they
synthesize key vitamins and metabolites
and neurotransmitters so I think it's
time you started doing something for
them too and the best place to start is
with seed seeds daily symbiotic combines
a whopping 24 different probiotic
strains in one single dose these are
strains you're not going to find in
yogurt or other fermented foods but
rather already naturally occurring in
the human body these strains have been
studied to deliver systemic benefits for
digestion skin heart and gut immune
function there's just no other probiotic
with this much clearly referenced
clinical work behind their formulation
if this world of probiotics and microbes
fascinates you or you want to learn more
about seed and their products and the
people behind it I would urge you to
check out my conversation with seed
founders or a cats and rajah Durer that
is episode 445 in the archives we go
deep it's a good one in any event I've
become a total seed convert I take their
daily symbiotic every single day and I
of it to learn more about the science
behind it go to seed comm ford slash
rich roll to get 20% off your first
month of the daily symbiotic that's seed
sce.com slash rich roll or use the code
rich roll to get 20% off okay so as I
mentioned this episode in so many ways
marks a milestone in my life that I will
always look back on somewhat astounded
very proud and perpetually humbled if
you're stuck in a version of my past and
can't see your way forward my hope is
that this conversation will help spark
something in you inspire you to perhaps
think differently and more openly about
possibility and ultimately embolden you
to embark upon your version of what I've
been blessed to experience to do the
inside work to see yourself and all your
beauty and character defects more
objectively so you can set a better
trajectory to face and ultimately
overcome those shortcomings I hope it
will open you to the experience of
courage that occurs when you walk
through fear and help you breathe just a
little bit more life into the more self
actualized authentic self within if you
enjoy what is momentarily to follow you
can find the outside podcast and all the
usual podcast places and at outside
online.com forward slash podcast I want
to thank Michael Peter and everyone at
outside for helping share my story
including Bo Greely for his cover image
and wonderful photography it all means
more to me than you guys can possibly
imagine so without further ado please
enjoy
just relax that is the big idea behind
outside magazines current issue and to
be honest is to kind of improve your
health message we tend to deliver every
January just like a lot of other media
outlets have start of the new year
people are looking for guidance on how
to meet their lofty resolutions and
we're happy to deliver hey we need to do
but what many past January issues have
focused on fitness and athletic
performance this year we really wanted
to help our readers chill out goal was
to provide remedies for the frenetic
angst-ridden state of being that we all
seem to be experiencing these days it
seems that everyone is constantly
overworked we're all so bombarded by
terrifying news about the climate
we're pickled mangry politics and we
respond by rebooting our nutrition
ramping up our workouts hacking our time
to supercharge our productivity it's all
exhausting and it's not helping that in
mind we wanted to create an issue
offering alternative strategies to point
the opposite direction away from all the
striving and towards relaxing from the
moment we set out on this plan we knew
who we wanted to put on the cover
rich role the massively popular podcast
host and vegan athlete who was an icon
for radical life transformation he or
someone was faced addiction boldly
abandoned his career as a lawyer to
chase his passion for endurance sports
found a purpose in his recovery as a
weekly show roll interviews everyone
from elite athletes to spiritual leaders
to best-selling authors only interest
humbly empowering the rest of us to make
better decisions the entrepreneur and
life coach Jesse it's ler aptly said
that role is like the endurance athlete
version of Oprah and so we sent frequent
outside contributor Peter Victor on to
Southern California to spend some time
with role he started by attending a live
edition of the rich roll podcast held in
LA's Wilshire Ebell theatre a role
interviewed the environmentalist Paul
Hawke
most memorable moment of that evening it
actually came in rolls introduction when
he threw out a planned speech and
instead read an email he'd gotten from
one of his listeners and I thought that
it would be good to read this one
because the person who sent it to me
happens to be here this evening so bear
with me this is from Ron Ron writes hi
rich I'm headed to LA tomorrow to join
you for the live podcast event and very
excited for the experience we met at the
conscious capitalism CEO summit coming
on two years ago we had lunch with a
small group and I shared with you
afterwards that my 16 year old son was
in treatment for drug and alcohol
addiction you said the greatest thing to
me and that was Wow
what I would have been able to have done
with my life if I learned the recovery
skills at 16 versus 40 wrote 40 was
actually 31 but and that comment gave me
hope I also started listening to your
podcast on a regular basis and it has
been part of my journey to be a better
father husband and leader I get to share
that through my involvement as the
founder and board chair of conscious
capitalism Kansas City so thank you
shelfing back to this week my son that I
mentioned will be in the audience with
me he is now 18 he's been accepted to
LMU in Los Angeles for fall of 2 2020
he is at LMU this week taking part in
the dedication of their new lions for
recovery center in the Student Union and
speaking on a panel sharing his story
right
and this is the part that got me so you
were right and I learned that recovery
gives expansion and not contraction
recovery gives expansion and not
contraction I appreciate you for being a
light and inspiration to us to live
better lives and create a better world
with gratitude
Ron Ron Hill are you here can you stand
up and wave and your son Alec I can't
see the crowd but there you are
two days after that event big Nura went
to rolls home in the Santa Monica
Mountains where he lives with his wife
the vegan cookbook author Julie Payette
and the youngest two of their four
children I sat down in rolls home
recording studio to talk about his long
journey he'd grown up in a suburb of
Washington DC where he attended an
all-boys prep school he was extremely
hard-working a strong student and a top
swimmer it wasn't the kind of kid who
got into trouble that change though when
he started getting recruited by college
swim teams part of the whole like
recruiting trip thing is you party right
and like apparently been to parties in
my life but here I am going to house
parties and going to bars and all this
kind of stuff and that was really kind
of my first real introduction to alcohol
and there's a there was this one time I
was recruited to the University of
Michigan the coach at the time is John
herb and Chuck still my favorite coach I
he's like the most amazing swim coach in
the world and Michigan was very much on
the rise and I have a personal family
connection to the University of Michigan
my mom went to the University of
Michigan and my dad went to law school
at the University of Michigan everybody
and my family and extended family is
from Michigan they're all they all bleed
maize and blue and my grandfather who
died before I was born was captain of
the University of Michigan swim team I
believe in 1928 I'm not mistaken he held
an American record in the 150 meter
backstroke or yard backstroke which is
not an event anymore of it was at the
time an Olympic hopeful he barely missed
a berth for the
you know he was like a peer of Johnny
Weiss Mueller in that era of swimming so
this is the legacy with which I go on
this recruiting trip to the University
of Michigan and there was a dual meet
that weekend which I was able to watch
and then following that there was a
house party so I'm at this house party
with all the swimmers and there's a keg
and there's it's a good time you know
happening and and I remember you know
being given like a big gulp thing of
beer to drink and drinking it I've got
this buzz on and one of the divers Bruce
Campbell who was was the second most
famous diver in the world at that time
behind Greg Louganis whose father was
the diving coach at the University of
Michigan dick Kimble legendary diving
coach Bruce also liked to party
and he pulled off right in front of me
the greatest party trick I have ever
seen today which is he was holding a cup
of beer keg beer and from from from
being flat-footed he jumped in the air
and did a did a backflip holding this
cup of beer and landed and did not spill
one drop of this beer and I just my mind
was blown I couldn't believe it and I
just thought whatever that guy has I
want it and I was all in I was like if
that guy can party like that and do what
he's done it was like I was like I want
to be a part of this community and like
it was almost like this permission to
drink in a way that I felt prior to that
was like not okay
suddenly it felt like it was okay like
this is what yeah like look at this guy
and what he's done with his life
now for those that don't know fast
forward to what you know happened in the
not-too-distant future of Bruce Kimball
which was that he he was drunk and he
plowed into I believe I don't want to
get this wrong I may have this a little
bit wrong but I believe he plowed into a
group of people drunk
killed somebody went to prison you know
he basically you know was an alcoholic
who suffered very dire consequences as a
result of being an alcoholic so what I
thought was cool ultimately turned out
to be something very dark and and I had
to experience my own version of that
later on but rich didn't go to Michigan
he chose Stanford which was another
powerhouse for swimmers it was a big
change for a kid from the East Coast and
rich made the swim team as a walk-on I
arrived on that campus and just fell in
love with everything about it it was so
different from growing up in Washington
and there was an openness to it and it
seemed like everybody that I'd met had
something unique and cool about them
like it was such an incredibly dynamic
and supportive environment and I thrived
in it you know I felt like I could be
myself I was doing well academically and
I showed up ready to go like I showed up
in shape for swimming because I realize
like I'm walking onto this team and I'm
gonna be training with Pablo Morales and
John Moffat and Jeff cast off I mean
these were the absolute legends of the
time like and if I expect to be of any
value to this team I've got to earn my
spot and I can't mess around so my first
meet it was against Texas we were number
one they were number two and I almost
won the 200 butterfly like my very first
duel me against Billy Stapleton who
would kind of famously go on to being
Lance Armstrong's agent it was it was a
very it was a very positive auspicious
start for this young walk-on freshman
who by the way had suffered a crack rib
like the week before because I was drunk
at a football game you know so the
cracks in the you know it's like you
could kind of it was a foreshadowing of
what would of what would soon you know
come to pass by the spring of his
freshman year rich was drinking four or
five nights a week but he didn't think
he had a problem
this was college and he felt like he was
just having fun still he did start to
notice that when everyone else would be
headed home he was the guy staying out
over time he says the drinking eroded
his ambition and his self-confidence his
swimming career peaked when he was a
freshman he got slower the next year and
in the spring of his junior year he quit
the team after that rich says he
wandered pretty much aimlessly for a
long time he graduated Stanford and he
went to law school mostly because they
didn't know what else to do even got
engaged but the marriage ended during
the honeymoon a huge sign that something
was very wrong with his life around the
same time he had moved to Los Angeles to
work for an entertainment law firm and
proceeded to get arrested twice in two
months for drunk driving second time
proved to be an important turning so the
second DUI that I got got pulled over
was like 2:00 or 3:00 in the morning
driving the wrong way down a one-way
street in Beverly Hills get pulled over
blood alcohol tested 0.27 I think
arresting officer confiscates my wallet
like seize my business card in my wallet
realizes that he knows my boss calls my
boss who was a prominent litigator in
Los Angeles who had done a lot of work
for the LAPD in the Beverly Hills Police
Department over the years it says I
picked up one of your boys so Monday
morning I'm you know I go to jail for
the night but I get out of jail and I'm
just gonna show up at work pretend like
nothing happened no even though my
license has been suspended this is two
duis in a row like I'm living in a
dreamland you know cuz basically I'm
going to jail and I'm pretending like
everything's fine boss calls me in says
I got an interesting phone call over the
weekend like I don't want to get
involved in your personal life but like
sounds like you know your shits upside
down dude like and I can't have that we
were preparing for a trial at the time
where I was going to second-chair this
trial was very intense work period so
he's like I need you to call this lawyer
this is gonna be your guy and you know
just solve it like I don't want to hear
about it of course this lawyer was
extremely
if he's like you know high-powered you
know criminal lawyer in Los Angeles
his name is charlie and Charlie just
gave it to me straight he's like you're
drunk you're going to jail you know I'm
not a I'm not a miracle worker here like
you know look look at this on paper like
you this is what you given me to work
with like you're gonna go to jail dude
and that really scared me you know
really really scared me because it was
like the venires of denial we're
starting to you know fall away and I was
starting to get a picture of the truth
of how I was living and then this really
remarkable thing happened which is the
file the court file for my first DUI got
lost and I was never prosecuted for that
so that just disappeared and went away
out of the blue Charlie's like you don't
understand I've been practicing law for
40 years I've never seen that happen
once so I go to court for the second one
and I get probation and basically you
know my license is stripped you know
I've got there's things I have to do and
I've got to go to you know and get court
Carson all that but like I didn't have
to go to jail it was this gift that
should never have happened
and that's when I realized like you know
I'm being looked out for like something
else is going on because that doesn't
make any sense whatsoever now that
doesn't mean that I was struck sober I
never drank again like I had a very in
elegant you know nonlinear relationship
with recovery for a period of months
after that but ultimately you know I
reached that point that you here with
other people in in recovery that that
point of no return where you wake up and
you finally have the willingness to do
whatever it takes and and that's when I
ended up in a in a rehab in Oregon roll
was 31 years old when he went to rehab
initially expected to stay at the Center
for just a couple weeks that's not what
happened
and when I got there I just realized
that like when the fog started to clear
I just realized the gravity of my
situation and how how horribly wrong you
know I had I had gone and I never wanted
to be in this place again and I really
developed the the willingness to just do
whatever it was going to take to create
a foundation of sobriety so that I could
you know basically reinvent myself when
I started telling the truth and being
honest about how I was actually living
they were like you have a case of
alcoholism we typically only see in
lifelong drinkers like 65 year old dudes
and you know if you don't figure this
out like you you're you you're gonna die
you know it's like this is not a joke
and we think we know you want to get
back into the world and blah blah blah
but you know and it's your choice but we
really think you should stay longer and
I just said I'll stay as long as you you
think I should and I ended up staying a
hundred days roll describes his early
years of recovery like a mission to fix
everything he had broken while he'd been
drinking when about this with a lot of
intensity but he also ignored other key
aspects of a healthy and fulfilling life
and when I got sober my goal was to
repair all the wreckage that I created
as a result of my drinking and using
like I had the fall from grace was so
precipitous like I had been this person
with all this potential and I squandered
it and there was so much shame about
that and I was like I really was intent
upon becoming a productive member of
society you know somebody who who who
could earn another person's respect and
who could show up on time and like do
all this stuff and that involved
repairing the relationship with my
family and with friends and all of that
and you know I was very dedicated to
that and I was successful in that so
between 31 and 39 I had bridged that gap
and you know successful as a lawyer
you know in good with my friends and
family again and and kind of had gotten
all the stuff like I was driving a
sports car and like you know she was
building this house and it just all
looked really groovy but what I what I
what I hadn't done was enough of the
inside work to come to terms with the
fact that I was chasing somebody else's
life
even though in rehab I was introduced to
these spiritual principles about how to
live and I had and I had grabbed onto
those and had made progress like I had
figured out a way to no longer use drugs
and alcohol and to kind of expand my
horizons on the possibilities for my
life I was still very much you know in
the in the amateur leagues of
understanding how to apply those
principles to my life and in a
fundamental and tactile way and I was
pursuing this career out of ego and fear
and insecurity not because it was my my
passion for what I wanted my life to
look like and so what happened was the
pain of that experience caught up to me
in the same way that the pain of my
drinking and using ultimately did and it
culminated in this evening shortly
before my 40th birthday when I was
walking up a simple flight of stairs
after a long day of work and had
tightness in my chest and was out of
breath like I couldn't walk up a simple
flight of stairs without taking a break
and and that realization like that was
another breaking of the denial because I
still thought of myself on the stanford
swimmer but i was carrying around 50
pounds extra around the midsection you
know i didn't really look in the you
know if I was honest with myself I was
so far away from that human being
because during this that that eight nine
year period
I was like a workaholic like I wasn't I
was eating you know it's just junk food
junkie and take-out food in the law firm
and not exercising and just working this
70 80 hour weeks and all that kind of
stuff in pursuit of this other person's
life and so the existential crisis kind
of collided with this realization about
my poor health and that was the the
perfect brew like the you know these
this collision of ingredients that
created this second moment of reckoning
and I think because I had experienced
that by like going to rehab and
realizing how much my life had changed
by making one simple decision I had
enough self-awareness to realize you
know on that staircase that I was being
revisited by a very similar opportunity
and that if I grabbed onto it
perhaps I could make another you know
big change like this is another bottom
but it's also another opportunity and
and I did that and that's really kind of
what set in motion everything that's
followed the first big change role made
after a second moment of reckoning was
to overhaul his diet with the
enthusiastic support of his wife truly
Pyatt we'd married just a couple of
years into his recovery he became a
vegan he also began exercising again
swimming and running wasn't anything
crazy at least not at first but he was
where claiming his fitness quickly and
feeling good soon he was running five or
six miles at a time and then very
unexpectedly I was supposed to be
another routine run he just kept going
on these trails and I was just gonna run
for 45 minutes or an hour and I just I
had one of those moments that every
runner is familiar with where you kind
of drop into this flow state and you
feel bulletproof and and like you can
run forever and you know each mile you
feel stronger than than the one before
and I'd never experienced that before
and just decided to go with it and
ultimately ended up running like 24
miles and you know four hours I'm out of
the trails like the craziest thing like
the last thing I thought would happen
and and another you know kind of moment
of you know realizing that maybe my life
could look different
like like either these lifestyle changes
I've made are more profound than I
anticipated or and/or like I've unlocked
this potential or this gene that was
dormant or that I didn't even know that
I had and and you know if my journeys
been about anything it's about kind of
trusting those whispers and and being
willing to have faith and invest in
those little signals that are just so
faint and yet potentially life-altering
and meaningful the whispers in this case
were clearly telling him to start
training harder and with more focus
which he did he also signed up for his
first triathlon it didn't go so well
he started throwing up during the swim
and he wasn't able to finish and yet he
enjoyed it so he hired a coach and he
began hunting around for another event
to enter he wanted something really
really hard what he found was Ultraman
which is essentially a double length
Ironman around the Big Island of Hawaii
this race that very few people know
about that had been around for a very
long time and was really more of a
spiritual Odyssey than an athletic event
every year Jane Bacchus the director of
this race would handpick 35 people from
all over the world to participate not
necessarily the best athletes but people
she felt like could benefit the most
from having this kind of experience it's
a self supported race you bring your own
crew over this three day period you
circumnavigate this entire island it's a
race and it's a world championship and
there are athletes that are vying for
that title but ultimately the greater
goal is that every single person athlete
and crew member be transformed as a
result of going on this collective
three-day caravan and that really
connected with me and I was like that's
what I'm looking for like that is the
experience that I'm missing in my life
and I want to feel like what it would
feel like to embark upon something so
difficult like it it bent my mind that
people could actually do this double
Ironman thing was insane but once I got
comfortable with that it was like
this is not about a race this is about
like broadening your perspective on who
you are and connecting with yourself in
a really profound way before he could
compete well let he get accepted into
the event
his only credential was not finishing a
much shorter triathlon but he called the
Ultraman race director anyway and he
told her his story she didn't say no
though she didn't say yes either she
said maybe which was all the
encouragement role needed so he had a
coach a training plan and a goal his
biggest challenge role was still Aloha
I'm working trying to make a living I'm
training for this race and this is like
now the idea of like the digital nomad
is so widely accepted but this was a
period of time where the internet was
still pretty new like using it for for
much else other than email was not
really like that functional so the the
notion that like this lawyer is gonna
have to like pull over off his bike and
like handle a conference call like in
the middle of the day you know thinking
like everybody's in suits and their
offices like if they could see me now
time trying to play it off like I'm in
an like there was a it was a shell game
for a while I was living this double
life like I was pursuing this one area
but also trying to hold myself out as
this like person who's in the office all
day long have all my stuff in my truck
and you know I would I would just go
wash myself off in gas station bathrooms
and you know have changes of clothes and
have all my training gear with me so I
literally was like camping sort of all
the time roll was eventually accepted
into the 2008 Ultraman and he stunned
everyone at the event including himself
by finishing an 11th place overall the
third among Americans convinced he could
do even better he signed up again in
2009 but while out on a training ride on
his bike in the Southern California
Hills that spring he crashed badly
smashing his head and face so hard that
even today he can't feel his lower lip
he still has scars on his face rawrr
doesn't remember much from the accident
but he doesn't recall being in the
emergency room with his wife I'm
wondering if he should quit
that really made me question you know
the the wisdom and what I was doing like
I've got kids like I'm a lawyer like
what are you doing man
you know like crack your head wide open
like for what you know and you know it
was a it was a it was a moment in which
I really had to get clear on truly what
it was that I wanted to do and Julie
said to me as I was laying in that bed
like if it this was it and it was all
done like would you do it again is this
do you regret it like it you know what
do you want your life to be I was like I
know I this is what I want to do she's
like good then do it it wasn't that I
had answered all the questions that I
had for myself but I felt like my
compass was being calibrated somehow not
in the sense that this was gonna be a
vocation but but there was something
about what I was trying to do and what I
was pursuing that just felt in alignment
like I felt like this is the direction I
need to go in and I haven't I can't see
past two weeks from now in terms of
where this is gonna lead me
I just feel convicted that that the
answers that I seek are gonna be
discovered and revealed by continuing to
pull on this thread rather than
reverting back to what I know and his
next Ultraman role finished the first
day leading the field by ten minutes and
on day two he crashed his bike again and
he lost any chance at a podium finish he
struggled on through a lot of pain and
he ended up finishing six beating his
time from the year before by two hours
and that was incredible because the
challenge of crashing and having to pick
yourself back up is really what reveals
character like that's the test executing
a race at the highest level and having
everything go your way isn't exactly the
learning experience that I was looking
for that I needed like to me it was a
perfect race because I had crashed and I
was like I didn't want to finish the
race and my ego was shattered and all of
that I still had to pick it up and
finish it and like I learned more about
myself as a result of that than I ever
could if everything had gone my way so
you know I loved everything about how
that ended up but it still left me
thinking like I have capacities that I
didn't realize that I had pushing the
limit
to those capacities but in order partner
with endurance athlete Jason Lester to
take on something the two of them dubbed
the epic five and have him doing five
Iron Man's on five Hawaiian Islands in
under a week there was another inspiring
life-changing experience
meanwhile though real life matters
things like the responsibilities of
earning money and taking care of your
home and your family they were becoming
increasingly difficult to manage at the
same time the only reason roll was able
to do it he says was because of the
strength and dedication of his wife even
during later years when they were on the
verge of losing everything
Julie's faith and what they were doing
never faltered we went through an
extended dark night of the soul
Julie calls it our our dismantling yeah
we went through many years of not being
able to pay our mortgage we had our
trash bins taken away because I couldn't
pay the 60 bucks or 80 bucks or whatever
it was just putting food on the table
was a struggle we had cars repossessed
that like it was really challenging and
really humiliating and there were plenty
of times where I thought I was insane
how could I you know like I was this
person who was in this place and now
I've gone through all of this and now
here I am and this is what we're dealing
with like I must really be insane or
what is fundamentally wrong with me and
Julie would be like no everything is the
way it's supposed to be and we are we
are burning in the fires because we're
being prepared for something else and I
was like you're insane you know I'm very
rational and she has shown me time and
time again the limits of that operating
system and the expansiveness that can be
experienced when you let go of that and
allow yourself to live more in integrity
with your inspiration and your intuition
which is a very difficult delicate
ephemeral thing to do but I really do
have to like I would not be doing any of
these things if left to my own devices
and it was really her strength that that
gave me the
permission to continue to to move in
this direction from alcoholic to
workaholic the plant powered endurance
hero who's willing to risk it all to
pursue an enlightened path
sounds like the making of a hell of a
book which it was roll published finding
ultra in the spring of 2012
the thing is though the book wasn't
actually his idea and came from another
former swimmer at Stanford who was early
in his own addiction recovery when he
read a short blurb about role in the
alumni magazine he reached out to roll
because he was looking for people to
talk to people who would understand they
had regular conversations for months
until at one point the guy says hey your
story's amazing you should write a book
does it happen this person also knew the
agent of Dean Karnazes the superstar
ultra runner whose book about his
transformation had been a breakout hit
sounds like another lucky moment in the
saga of rich roll but as he sees it it's
also a result of his enduring commitment
to addiction recovery and I look at it
as a function of putting sobriety first
you know like my my only goal was to be
of service to this person who was newly
sober you know and everything good in my
life has come as an outgrowth of putting
service first and recovery first and
just letting like sort of allowing
whatever else is gonna come come
we're also credits recovery for teaching
him how to understand and tell his own
story and to listen and interpret other
people's stories these are valuable
skills when you're writing a memoir or
when you go on to create a podcast what
you learn in in the secret society rooms
of recovery that we're not allowed to
talk about you you you develop a huge
capacity for empathy and you learn how
to be vulnerable you learn how to tell
the truth and you learn to listen and
you get practiced in telling your story
you sit and you listen to other people
share their story and you learn from
their courage and their vulnerability
and
emotional journey and then it's your
turn to go do that and over the years
you get better and the story starts to
teach you what's important about it and
what is impactful and helpful to other
people so I learned how to share my
story in those rooms
I learned to be vulnerable I learned to
be comfortable expressing my truth and
my emotions and my weaknesses and
failures and the like all of that comes
from recovery and I think it's
interesting that a lot of successful
podcast hosts are in recovery that's not
a mistake because you learn you learn
the craft of storytelling and you learn
how to emotionally connect with other
people and and I think that's that's how
I learned how to get up in front of
people on stage and how I learned to be
a good host and learn how to be a good
listener when I have guests on the day
finding ultra came out roll
ceremoniously did not renew his bar
membership he was done being a lawyer
and all in on this new life pursuing his
passion and wasn't as glorious as you
might think
hence assured in a very long extended
period of time in which the phone did
not rank which ushered in financial
hardship for many years a lot of
uncertainty about what life would look
like and doubt and it made me think I'm
just full of like I just wrote this
book and I talk about all these
spiritual principles and how you have to
like do the inside work and trust your
heart and follow that and all of that
I'm like you are so full of man
look at your life it's a disaster right
now you're not an example for anything
we were on the precipice of losing our
house like you know the the material
world was kind of collapsing on top of
me and there's this narrative out in the
world or on the internet like oh rich
writes this book and starts this thing
and it's all gravy and like oh is a New
York Times best seller it was not a New
York Times bestseller it did okay and it
found a little audience but it wasn't
like this book that then just captured
the fascination of the
you know it wasn't like that at all roll
was thrown a lifeline by a wealthy
friend invited him in his family to stay
on a property he owned in Hawaii where
he was establishing an organic farm the
friend asked role to help him develop
some community pieces for the project I
lived in yurts it was an adventure of
sorts but one that soon gave roll a case
of island fever and the wake of the book
he was eager to figure out his next
thing and hungry for another creative
outlet during his long hours of
endurance training roll had listened
hours upon hours of podcasts and fawn in
love with the medium now he thought
maybe I could do something and when I
looked at the health space there was
some interesting stuff but I didn't feel
like I felt like there was a lot of
opportunity there because there just
wasn't that much you know and we were in
Kauai we were with my sons who had all
this musical equipment and microphones I
spent a day going online trying to
figure out how you start a podcast and
once I solve that just turned a
microphone on and my wife and I started
talking and that was it you know and it
was fun I thought let's do that again
tomorrow
from the outset we all knew what kind of
show we wanted to create it would be one
focused on his guests not himself also
he didn't want to host a podcast that
was only for athletes it was very clear
from episode one like this is not gonna
be about me and it's not gonna be about
triathlon no it's like this is not gonna
be a training podcast like I've grown to
a certain point and there's so much
growth to be had like I want to continue
to grow and I want to bring on people
who can help do that though I can do
that with who can teach me and who are
those people and and how can I create
what I would have liked to have
discovered 10 15 years earlier when I
was trying to figure out who I wanted to
be and I felt like I couldn't be
anything other than what other people's
expectations for me were what if I could
create a curriculum that could empower
people to
make better decisions about the
trajectory of their lives and that was
really the kind of subtext or philosophy
that has you know kind of empowered the
whole the whole thing another one of his
guiding principles is to avoid labels
all isn't totally comfortable with the
idea that he's part of the wellness were
self-help industries he says he's really
just following his curiosity his hope is
to share conversations that help people
to make real lasting changes I'm trying
to catalyze people into action
right and I think there is there is
something to be said for people that
read lots of self-help books and think
that they're changing their lives but
they're not actually implementing any of
that advice they're just reading it and
then they have a self-awareness like oh
this person said this isn't that amazing
and it's like they're just they're not
making any changes in how they're living
so I am aware of that but but I'm
constantly talking about action you know
what are the actions that you're taking
it's it's not how you feel about things
it's not you know the idea that you have
about them it's like it all boils down
to like what are you doing after
launching his podcast which role didn't
take a break for seven years every week
he faithfully uploaded a new episode
someone who works in podcasting I can
tell you that is insane
role finally recognize this which is why
he just took a month off he unplugged
for all of December we did pre record a
number of episodes beforehand this was
podcast kept rolling while he was gone I
think for many years I've been burning
on I've been sort of fuelled by this
unsustainable fuel source of like fear
and desperation because who because you
know that that dark night of the soul
and that that like dismantling was so
traumatic it left me with a PTSD and now
like everything's working and
and like it's all awesome but I feel
like I'm done I got a double down I
gotta work hard I worked hard because
like it was so hard before that I just
don't want to miss this opportunity and
it's taken me a while to realize that
like I don't have to burn so hot you
know like I have that and that if I want
to keep doing this I really need to take
a break and I haven't taken a vacation
in seven years and I feel like I really
need to do that so I'm gonna go
completely off off radar for an entire
month so that I can come back in the new
year
so how'd that one go down for you I
can't objectively assess this when the
mics are turned around and I'm the one
doing the talking you guys are gonna
have to decide for yourself something a
little bit different I thought it was
cool I hope you guys enjoyed that do me
a big favor show the folks at outside
magazine a little bit of love you can
find them everywhere at outside magazine
and you can find the outside podcast
available in all the usual podcast
places and at outside online.com forward
slash podcast if you'd like to support
the work we do here on the show
subscribe rate and comment on it on
Apple podcasts or on Spotify if you're
on Android and YouTube for the visually
inclined share the show or your favorite
episodes with friends or on social media
I love seeing all the screen grabs on
Instagram floating around and you can
always support us on patreon at
richworld com4 / donate this episode was
produced written and edited by michael
roberts interview by peter vigorón and
music by Robbie Carver with additional
audio engineering and production by
Jason camiolo I also want to thank
Jessica Miranda for graphics vogue
really for portraits DK for advertisers
of relationships Georgia Whaley for
copywriting and theme music by analemma
I love you all I will see you back here
in a couple days until then stay true be
true peace plants
[Music]